naturel aventure le premier challenge
électro féminin au monde et yvelinois un
rally d'une semaine à lyon véhicules
électriques et trekking ou encore
orientation dimanche les équipes ont
quitté versailles pour se lancer
officiellement dans la course ce lundi
31 mai le départ a été donné à annemasse
en haute-savoie un évènement 100%
féminin au projet est vraiment en faveur
de l'environnement en faveur de la
mobilité électrique est vraiment on a
souhaité dire qu'avec une voiture
électrique on est capable de faire un
rallye et parce qu'on est des femmes on
est également capable de s'orienter
objectif conduire de façon économe
franck dubosc parrain de cette première
édition soutient la cause depuis le
départ fictif à versailles
l'artiste s'est allié à ce projet en
faveur de l'environnement
allié à presque chaque événement dont
quelque chose écologique s'est montré à
tout le monde que bach c'est important
et puis qu'on peut le faire surtout
qu'on peut le faire et que c'est assez
facile de le faire
dallier l'écologie à n'importe quel
événement voilà donc je trouve que c'est
c'est une c'est une belle cause
je trouve que l'écologie surtout en ce
moment c'est une belle cause parce
qu'elle doit nous réunir tout ce n est
pas l ai pas clivante
douze équipes ont décidé de relever le
défi chaque binôme américaine de
formation pour apprendre à s'orienter un
challenge déconnecté sans gps ni
téléphone
mais avec carte et boussole ce sera une
expérience enrichissante de
d'orientation puisque que ce soit en
voiture ou à pied lors des treks on a
quarter pour seul et puis l'intérêt de
ce projet c'est que tout ce qu'on tout
l'argent qu'on a qu'on a pu lever pour
ce but ce projet sera reversée à des
associations en faveur de
l'environnement
objectif pour les équipes parcourir 1000
km en une semaine
retour prévu le vendredi 4 juin à evian
les bains